hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast nasa's gene lab project
public access to spaceflight omics data
it is presented by Sigrid ranch PhD a
scientist in the space Biosciences
research branch at NASA I am Judy
O'Rourke of lab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box that appears on the
screen we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen
or use the ask a question box to let us
know that you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
raunch I will now turn the presentation
over to her oh thank you for joining me
today which is our project for open
science for exploration it is that
project is housed out of NASA Ames
Research Center in California and I want
to just first acknowledge the members of
the project that have contributed very
much to this dr. saleon costs who is our
project manager Marla's mythic our
deputy project manager John Gasca who is
a project scientist and Ashley but has
Steve is also a senior scientist on the
project
so the brief outline of the talk is I'm
going to first introduce you to some of
the challenges of space flight then talk
about the opportunities of omics
technologies and then I'll the bulk of
the talk is going to go into the gene
lab itself what is what if the project
is the components of our data system and
our data system development how we
generate data for the project and then
finally the science that we can get out
of the genome project
so first the challenges of spaceflight
so this little diagram kind of shows the
challenges of human spaceflight and that
little human icon is in the center of
all of these different little images so
the main the main and the main risks to
humans exploration of space have to do
with all of these different five
different components that NASA's human
research program has defined and they
they define them as risks and these are
the risks that's that spaceflight
experiments hope to address in terms of
enabling us to get into beyond Earth
orbit to Mars to really do have
long-term exploration of space so these
are hostile closed environments
isolation and confinement the distance
from Earth space radiation and gravity
fields so I'll go into actually
especially space radiation I'm a little
bit further along in the talk and I'll
touch on some of these others these
other issues as well so the
opportunities of space of omics data so
[Music]
omics is the study of as you know the
biomolecules DNA RNA protein the
metabolites
cetera and a number of years ago that in
the 2011 and RC decadal survey the
mission of gene lab was basically
designed and so they basically
identified as a requirement that
genomics and transcriptomics proteomics
and metabolomics offer an immense
opportunity to understand the effects of
spaceflight on biological systems and
that the data should be able to be mined
and analyzed for information by multiple
researchers and this gave birth to gene
lab as a public database idea to
maximize the amount of data that we can
get from every biological experiment in
space and now actually omics acquisition
and spaces is a reality it started
initially with being able to do smart
PCR qrt-pcr on on ISS and being able to
actually using our Stanford sample
preparation module to actually go from
tissues or cells all the way to DNA RNA
and protein and more recently we've had
we've been able to do mini PCR run
experiments by students and also the
Oxford nanopore the minion gene
sequencer to actually sequence genes in
space and so this technology actually is
is a really important development for
the advancement of technologies in space
and the ability to use omics analyses
onboard ISS or whatever space vehicle
but right now we do all of the analysis
on the ground and so I'm going to talk a
little bit more about that so gene that
was a data system this is the kind of
the big picture of gene lab and it has a
number of different components and I'm
going to talk you through this slide
you'll see it multiple times during the
talk as I touch on the different
components right now gene lab hosts
primarily raw data so those are the gene
sequences RNA sequences
Reed's metabolomic mass spectra etc so
we those data are really currently if
you look at the left-hand side of this
slide interpretable by data side data
scientists and what one of the goals of
gene lab is to actually really
democratize that data so that it can be
interpreted by biologists and who are
not necessarily bioinformaticians and
then even by citizen scientists who are
interested in understanding what happens
in space to our genes so so the the
Phenom is actually has had a phased
implementation the first implementation
of our database was released in 2015 to
be able to house a number of datasets
and it really was very top level and
trying to understand actually what what
type of data would go into the database
in phase 2 was recently completed and in
those phases we had data you know being
able to download the data and accelerate
the data we're now in phase 3 and in
phase 3 we are going to be incorporating
tools we plan to be releasing a data
database in the fall which will
incorporate tools that the users can use
so here are some of the milestones that
I'll talk about in our talk aw geez our
ml analysis working group we're going to
be having some summer interns who are
gonna help us with tool development and
pipeline development and we are going to
be releasing in October that our version
3.0 at the AST s our meeting which is
the American Society for gravitational
and Space Research and then next year we
are going to be releasing a version with
a visualization portal so I will be
going through all this in a little bit
more detail
so the first thing is the the phase to
release which right now has a
google-like search and federated search
so right now on the left you see an
image of our database with some datasets
in there and actually what you see are
not just G there's a gene of data set at
the bottom which has a little rodent
icon you will also see three data sets
from geo so you can actually search
across multiple databases by searching
in are on the gene lab website and you
can within the gene lab website but not
including the other databases geo and
entity Rast you can actually do filters
for for the gene lab datasets so the
next item that I'm going to be talking
about are the different types of data
and so actually so the minute actually
the metadata sore one of the aspects of
our databases that we have very well
curated metadata and so we use the is is
a curator and in our phase two release
one of the one of the main things that
we did was we released it on an instance
of genomespace and what that has allowed
us to do is to have a much faster data
processing operation to actually get
data into the data into our database and
to really have a lot of very specific
controlled vocabulary for metadata and
using you know using oncology's from
[Music]
from various sources to be able to
control the data so what you see are
some images of the is a creator that the
that the user would use the user would
if you were putting data into gene lab
this is the form that you would use to
get your data into gene lab that curates
specifics about assay
type the sample names the actual
protocols and when you go to our website
you can actually download a copy of is a
creator and use that to view the data
within our datasets so what kind of data
do we have in teen lab right now we have
one hundred and sixty six data sets and
they're distributed by there we've had a
huge data growth in the in the last
several years some of it is is data that
we have put in and a lot of it comes
from spaceflight researchers around the
world that we have pulled in also from
other sources such as CEO so by species
you see that the bulk of our data are
Mouse and and plants and we had do have
some human data sets we have the
majority of our data is actually
spaceflight samples and then and the
majority is also transcriptomics and of
that most of that currently is
microarray data but that will be
shifting over this over the time so we
also have 69 ground data sets and those
are primarily radiation and simulated
microgravity data sets and we have had a
big push in the last year to include as
many radiation data sets as possible
and that's because this is one of the
major the major risks for spaceflight
and I'll go into that a little bit
further these these images are actually
from a paper that was recently published
as a commentary and radiation research
and so you can go there to read that
commentary a little bit more so this
little graphic shows oh my thumb didn't
come through sorry but basically that
that the Earth's gravitational field
actually shields us from a lot of the
cosmic rays and radiation and at the
bottom of the at the bottom of this
image you can see that that actually
and that actually is a space mission
outside the Earth's gravitational field
would really have huge consequences in
terms of exposure to radiation so one of
our big pushes in as well as including
as many ground radiation datasets is to
include the symmetry data from as many
different sources as we can for
spaceflight data and this this these
little these images show at the bottom
of the the bottom image shows those
symmetry locations on the Space Shuttle
so we have a number of data sets from
the Space Shuttle and we've completed
the tallying of data from those
dosimeter x' and actually included them
with the data sets that are in our
system and so on the right-hand side you
can see the different types of data sets
that we have in our system and these are
currently we only have the dosimetry
data for the space shuttle we will get
will be incorporating dosimetry data
from the international space station in
the near future so here you can see
different organisms plotted on here
humans at the top to microbes at the
bottom and the number of different data
sets that we have from those organisms
and the total dose of radiation that
they've received so you can see that we
have a number of space flight data that
incorporates radiate radiation dosimetry
so and if you want to actually see that
data this is a this is the view of our
website again you can click on the tab
that's called environmental data and go
to that and what you'll see is a display
like this that shows each individual
flight that or experiment and the the
GLD s number on the left is in each one
is an individual investigation and
the dosimetry data from that from each
of those individual dosimeter z' and the
averages that we will that we use to
interpret so going through this a little
bit further i'm going to tell you some
more about how do we actually get data
into our system and so we have this this
in this release we have this cloud and a
stack laborat of workspace and so you so
users can go in and actually create an
account and they can upload their data
to the gene-lab system through that
mechanism and so this is our current
mechanism for incorporating data into
our account so if you notice if you are
an investigator that has spaceflight or
Space Flight relevant data then this is
the mechanism that you would use to
actually get into to get your data
uploaded into our system so in the we
also have this the galaxy platform and
this galaxy platform is a huge barrier
it's a huge solution to the great
barriers that we had for being able to
analyze and analyze large amounts of
data rapidly and allow that as a user
interface so some of the barriers to
omics to the analysis of omics data are
that they're the large files are
difficult to move around and process and
workflows vary from user to user and the
details are sometimes very poorly
documented so the galaxy platform solves
a lot of these it's an open source
extensible platform for a cloud-based
analysis of omics data so everything
happens in the cloud users can
drag-and-drop basically the the images
of the files but without actually having
to move the data around and so you don't
have to upload and download data to your
computer in order to do the analyses so
it allows a lot of command line very a
lot of flexibility and tool
scrips reproducibility of using those
pipelines and I'll talk a lot more about
that the workflows can be published
shared and downloaded and so this is a
huge push right now in gene lab is
actually getting and vetting the tools
that are going into our galaxy project
and making sure that those tools run on
all the different types of data making
sure that the the data names are the
data set names are have have are
properly described and so that we can
really develop a very fast and flexible
workspace for users to be able to
analyze data and for us to be able to
actually present process data to our
user community so and then in the next
part let's see I've talked about galaxy
and genomespace I'm going to talk a
little bit about our analysis working
groups so our analysis working groups
we recently divided set these up at the
beginning of the year and they comprise
more than 60 scientists at all different
levels who are have most of them have
expertise in bioinformatics either
transcriptomics proteomics metagenomics
and we are divided into four different
groups so we have a plant group a
microbes group an animals group and a
multi-omics group and we have virtual
munchies little monthly meetings where
each meeting each group meets
individually with their with the team
members and we have members from all
over the world so most of our AWT
members are in the US but we have a few
currently in europe we anticipate having
more members from around the world as
things progressed we recently had on AWG
we filmed the æther beauty analysis
working groups we recently had an AW
workshop in orlando florida that was a
huge success where our AWG members are
held
to find consensus pathways for the
analysis of each of the types of data
that we have in our database and so we
are those consensus pipelines are what
we are going to be using to actually
process data to present as process data
on our website so that we can have
really very nice flexibility in terms of
the visualization of the data so so our
analysis working groups this is just
kind of a timeline of this year what's
going on so the goal is to answer very
specific questions and and to really
understand like what are the what are
the what kind of things might be missing
from gene land right now that and for
them to make recommendations about
metadata that might be included or not
only the two lines that I'm sorry the
analysis pipelines but tools that can be
that you should be including in our
galaxy workspace to be able to analyze
the data so this summer the
recommendations that that the analysis
working groups have come up with are
going to be implemented by student
interns we have a whole group of student
interns that we're going to be coming
this summer and actually crunching a lot
of data and getting that into our
release that will be happening in the
fall and so in the coming years that
will have basically the BG helping us
with developing visualization
requirements for our visualization
system so that goes to basically to this
the visualization portal that we help to
be released next year and we still have
a lot of questions about how that's we
we haven't figured out exactly exactly
how we're going to be able to implement
the visualization portal one of the so
I'm pulling up basically on the blue
side of this we have the user interface
so the user would be in our
acting with galaxies and the gene-lab
pipelines and they have their own
private workspace where they can either
pull the gene lab data or put their own
data up there to analyze in in
conjunction with the gene lab data on
the red side we have gene lab actually
processing data to present to the
general public so we have a high through
a high throughput high throughput
platform with our consensus pipelines at
the AWG has developed and so we will be
taking the data from the bottom from the
workspace and actually processing from
raw to lower order alignments and then
higher order differential display or
differential gene expression and systems
analyses and then ultimately that will
go into the sorry the visualization
portal and so the in the in the lower
basically we currently do not have any
human sequences in our database except
for what comes from cultured cells or
really de-identified human sequences we
do anticipate
really like to be able to present an
astronaut data and it should be possible
if we can include only higher-order data
on the public side so that they don't
see any of the raw data at all and that
we have a very we could have a very
controlled access to the raw data so
back to the outline we're going to go
into a little bit more about data
generation so this is kind of a typical
pipeline for how data is generated so we
have the development of experiment
objectives payload mission definition
and implementation for spaceflight
experiments then the experiment is
performed in space and then you can have
sample preparation on the ground and
omics central processing and data
curation and release and gene lab and so
gene Lim has started partnering or has
partnered
the number of scientists to generate
some of the data that is that is
involved in gene Lao so most of the
experiment a lot of the experiments that
come true gene lab are either partners
with individual experiment individual
scientists that are funded through NASA
slipshod which is the space life and
physical sciences research and
applications division and also partners
with cases which is the Center for
advancement of sex in space which is a
commercial side of the international
space station so these are just a couple
of examples of gene lab collaborations
where we collaborated with on Brick 19
and brick 20 with Simon Gilroy and Sarah
Wyatt on Arab adaxes experiments we also
collaborated with an asset with NASA on
Brick 23 which was a microbes experiment
and we've had multiple collaborations on
the rodent research series of
experiments which are run by NASA and
casus so rodent research one which was a
validation experiment and running
research three which was a muscle
particularly a muscle experiment and in
these collaborations being has been able
to either augment the experiments that
were proposed by the the proposed
proposed by for instance by doctors
Gilroy and Wyatt to give them more omics
analyses and they hadn't had originally
proposed or to get samples from the
rodent research experiments that are
from different tissues and the ones for
which the experiments were designed and
those are tissues that are obtained
through NASA's biospecimen sharing
program and with brick 23 being added
all of the sample processing of the
microbes and those experiments so gene
Lam has a sample processing laboratory
it's a it's a standard omics processing
laboratory for
generating DNA RNA protein and doing
dissections of some of the carcasses
from the spaceflight samples our
technicians are very well trained and
we're responsible for generating a huge
amount of the data that is in denial you
can see here on this graph on the on the
right hand side the data from these
individual experiments that I spoke to
you about were in research one were in
research three brick nineteen twenty and
twenty three so in terms of the rodent
research experiments this is just from
reading research one we also have to
choose from rodent research three this
experiment was launched in 2014 it was a
validation mission using c57 black 6
mouse and gene-lab obtained a whole
number of tissue a whole lot of tissues
liver adrenal i gastrocnemius kidney
quadricep soleus and tibia santaros and
they did RNA seek proteomic and
bisulfite sequencing on all of those
datasets and all of those datasets are
available in gene lam so publicly
accessible anybody can download that
data and analyze it so the last part of
the talk i've gotten all the way down to
talking about gene out of science so i'm
going to go through this fairly quickly
so we this is a general overview of some
of the teen lab - data on the on the
timeline in the middle you see the
number of days in space and then we have
bubbles going up and down from those
lines showing the different tissues from
rodents that have been sacrificed and
and the tissues harvested and that data
is now in gene lab so above in blue
above the line at the timeline our
tissues that were harvested from ISS
experiments and down below our runs that
were flown on the Space Shuttle so you
can see a wide variety of different
tissues all of these all the data
these experiments is available in gene
lab so when gene lab has started to do
some of the analysis on these tissues is
with that we saw some very expected
things so we saw changes to muscles and
so here you just see some principal
component analysis and this and the
samples cluster by tissues so you see
liver down on the bottom right but
bottom left and I and gastric and and an
adrenal are up at the top and then all
the muscle are clustered on the right
hand side so you definitely see very
expected changes in in muscle in
particular so if you look at slight
versus ground and the graph that I just
pulled up the differential gene
expression showed us that you definitely
have some changes between flight and
ground and here on the graph on the
right blue is flight and red is is
ground and in particular we see changes
in the myosin heavy types in between
spine and ground so what one of the
things that we found from analyzing this
data were things that we didn't expect
so the first one was what we call cage
effects and this is now published data
recently published in Nature reports or
scientific reports pardon me and so this
study examined this is all an analysis
of data that's housed in gene lab
publicly available and what our
scientists did was they only looked at
actually control experiments they didn't
they looked at only ground controls in
this in this analysis and what they
compared was the different cage types on
the left you see the habitat for the
mice that scenes in space the middle
image is just a close-up through the
door of what the habitat looks like and
then on the right you see a standard by
barium cage and in this analysis they
used five different data sets and
examined just the ground control mice
and looked at differential gene analysis
from a number of different tissues
mostly muscle and then there was one rat
experiment with these mammary tissue so
this is the publication and I recommend
that I'm not going to go through the
data very quickly so you can just go to
the publication and actually look at the
data yourselves but the main point is
that that the analysis of actually the
housing suggests that carbon dioxide is
our mental stressor in spaceflight and
the reason that they say that is when
the way that they do the ground
experiments is they they match they get
recorded data from the International
Space Station of exactly the telemetry
from the the co2 monitoring system and
they match the co2 concentration in the
ground by barium controls so or I'm
sorry in the ground
AEM that the rodent habitat verse and
and they don't do that in the vivarium
controls those are just normal exposed
to the laboratory air whereas in the
library in the in the AEM they matched
the the oxygen and co2 levels exactly so
the mice are exposed to exactly the same
in air environment that they would be
exposed to on spaceflight and so what
you can see in the principal component
analysis is that there's there's very
clear clustering of the vivarium versus
the AEM data and so that suggests a very
strong cage effect and when our
scientists actually went in and analyzed
the data is that they found that
upstream regulators and canonical
pathways show responses is very tissue
specific so especially in the muscle and
has a and as highest for high co2 which
is what occurred in the AEM so these
types of experiments need to be
confirmed with the same types of
experiments but with ambient co2 levels
to see if those whether those whether
the stressors hypoxia indicators also
hold true at ambient sea low ambient co2
concentration
so this second unexpected symbol had to
do with sample preservation effects and
this had to do has to do with how polls
are processed on ISS so in a lot of
experiments that the rodents are flown
up and then back down the life but in
some experiments that the the mice are
actually sacrificed on the ISS and the
tissues can even be harvested
immediately for for various experiments
or the mice are can be just frozen and
then brought back down and then briefly
and then dissected after the freezing on
the ISS and so so what we did not did an
experiment where we also looked at the
control experiments looking at the
effects of dissecting from frozen
tissues and then our pilot experiment
and combined with the experiment from
actually this is just the flight
experiment looking at the the carcasses
that were brought down to earth and then
dissected on earth versus the ones that
were dissected in space and looking at
liver without their what they actually
in the principal component analysis they
actually were very definitely looked at
there as different pools and so this and
the thing is that in the ground controls
the same thing was was noted so there
was a strong separation of
differentially expressed genes between
the fresh and and the frozen tissues
either in space or on the ground and it
was worse in space so there are 4,000
G's that were in Commons principally
linked to catabolic pathways and that
kind of smells like tissue degradation
effects so this was the pre validation
experiment which was basically looking
at tissues frozen
immediately a section so in the middle
you see the time after dissection either
as soon as possible or waiting 25
minutes which is what we anticipated and
it might take an astronaut to be able to
dissect after dissecting other tissues
and/or dissected immediately and then
stored for for a year at minus 80
degrees so that so in the scenarios at
the bottom they're either either started
for three days after freezing I mean I
said stored for a year after a delay or
stored after immediate dissection and so
when we compared freezing these freezing
studies what we also found was this very
strong shift and clustering of the data
between those that were dissected from
carcasses so what we show here is both
flight and ground and so that all the
triangles our flight samples all the
circles our ground samples and all the
squares are what we call basal controls
and those are my setter killed directly
before the flight actually so they're
kind of as they've never experienced the
flight but they've been been in the
habitat for a short amount of time and
so what you can see here are basically
we had that that the the data clusters
with things that were frozen versus
things that were dissected immediately
upon euthanasia and so there's very
little overlap between those two
clusters to indicate things that happen
between slide and ground so you can see
that in the liver slide and ground
samples look very similar and the big
difference is between ones that were
dissected immediately or versus those
were those were frozen and then
dissected after being frozen so but what
we do see
in the flight samples actually we do see
some some differences in the liver so
and we can see metabolic pathways that
are changed and one of the things that
we've done with the delivery system
histology to show that actually you have
increases in oil red stained liver in
those samples and that was also shown in
the sts-135 flight STS 385 I'm sorry
it's light so basically this is fuel for
future experiments we are we're in the
process of looking at doing experiments
to to understand this effect on the
first and carcasses and to see whether
we can tease out the effect a little bit
further so engaging with Dean now how
can you participate in the gene lab
process and anybody can participate so
you can go to our website and you can
explore our data and coming in the fall
you'll be able to see some of our our
process process data showing up on the
on the on the website you'll also be
able to use our tools that are that
we're starting to populate and that but
haven't been it haven't been released to
the public we urge you to look at our
social media on Facebook Twitter and on
research gate we post updates constantly
and any news and opportunities will be
also on the front page of our gene lab
website help us democratize this data I
get in there and use the data we hope to
be able to go all the way from raw data
to understand disease states and to be
able to tackle those big questions to
help us get beyond the Earth orbit to
really explore space so here's the gene
lab team comprised mostly we have data
processing by our informaticians we
have programmers we have scientists and
we have worried people on our team and
we really look forward to you engaging
with us through our various media thank
you and now I'm ready for questions
Thank You dr. Rhines for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started
our first question is how can I submit
data to gene-lab so how can I submit
that's a great question so let me go
back up a little ways in the slides so
on our sorry on our web portal basically
we have this our collaborative workspace
so there's you know there's a little
button that says submit data and you
click on that you get basically you
created actually create a username on
this on our website and through there
you you actually also submit an email
that says what type of data you want to
submit to gene-lab so currently if you
we are accepting space flight data we
also accept what we call a space flight
relevant data so that can be experiments
that deal with radiation or other either
microgravity simulations so that could
be magnetic levitation or unloading
experiments or rotating mobis pyramids
or other types of microgravity
simulation experiments
and so you will get a you get a you'll
get a response from somebody on the
Gmail team who will kind of stuck me
through the process of how to upload
your data and in particular how to fill
out the metadata forms that we have
using that is a creator to populate the
metadata which is very critical for all
of our experiments and then you
basically upload the data it takes a
couple of weeks we actually have a
pretty fast process now for curating the
data and getting it released into our
system wonderful thank you next one is
is gene lab going to host the twins
study data well that's a great question
so as I talk a little bit here one of
the biggest problem with we're hosting
human data is for the identification of
the human data and currently GM has a
little bit of human data it's mostly
cell lines and there is also there are
some studies that are actually derived
from humans so it was so metagenomics of
[Music]
kind of micro microbiome type studies so
but actual human data from the twin
study we don't have current
authorization to host that although
there is a lot of desire to be able to
host that data and as I talked about in
this slide one way is to basically keep
it on the right-hand side in red so that
none of the raw data actually gets out
to the public and that we only show
processed data about the effects and so
you can't tell necessarily you know
basically if we have everything there
identified but when there's only two
people it's very hard to de-identify
that data the other possibility is that
we can host the data but have a very
controlled so that only people who are
authorized to view the data are able to
view that data well thank you I would
like to once again thank dr. Rhines for
her presentation
would also like to thank laberd's for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through August 10 2018 you'll receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that is all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye